so many things i want to talk to you
about but first let's talk about your
new book
battle of brothers you you delve really
deep into the relationship between
prince william and prince harry
do you think prince william could or
should have done more
to keep harry within the family working
as a senior member of the royal family
it's my opinion that william could and
should have done more for his brother
um there's such a couple
but it's somehow the nature of the
british royal system
um it's cruel um william's the
heir harry is the spare this is the
third
spare in the reign of elizabeth ii who
has come to grief
there was elizabeth and margaret older
viewers will remember
two little princess the little
princesses they were called playing
together
um they're like co-stars in the drama
and then as time goes by the queen
becomes the queen and margaret fades
away
with andrew much criticized figure but
still
to his credit he tried to earn a living
he tried to do business he tried to do
something special
that failed and now the same thing has
happened with
with harry um and uh the simple
explanation of what went wrong is that
when he married this american
superstar at least over here we thought
she felt we felt she was a superstar
maybe two superstar we might come on to
that and discuss it but anyway
that they they were the royal rock stars
and they dominated
the the royal scene from the time they
arrived
until really archie was born and then
they decided to leave
and that pushed william to the side
and it wasn't the royal way of doing
things and as i say
the royal system the british royal
system
which is your system as well in canada
um is pretty cruel um it's fine for the
firstborn
but everybody else gets pushed out of
the way and and that's what's happened
to
harry so you would say it's reasonable
that he wanted a private life
that he wanted to step down as a senior
member of the royal family
um my sympathies over the months have
come very much
towards harry and megan now i know
that's not the way people in this
country in britain feel when i say that
in my book
um when i say that in articles i get
furious angry letters
for for people in britain it's quite
simple megan was too big for her boots
as we say over here
um she just barged into the royal family
she wanted this she wanted that
and that's not the way this family works
and
you know there's some truth in that i
mean the british royal family
operates on restraint and rules and
that's not megan's style um
so um i think they are now yes
i think they're happy in america i think
they're going to stay in america
um and we're when we're talking about
their relations with the royal family
there are two aspects to this there's
the family relation
right how these brothers get on and i
think they will remain
friendly brothers i mean recently there
was an allegation of bullying
in the british papers and like a flash
within two or three hours
before lunchtime i remember the two
brothers had brought
out a um statement disavowing bullying
william didn't want to be seen as a
bully harry didn't want to be seen as
bullied
the two of them with their concern with
mental health didn't want anything to do
with the concept so that showed
how when it mattered they could get
together and i
i hope that'll be the basis of some sort
of relationship
personal relationship in the future but
i do not think
it will involve a working relationship
i think harry and megan they have these
dedicated ideas
women's rights social change these are
frankly
while the british royal family will do a
bit of lip service to them and say
they're too dynamic to be explored
they're too political really in the
context of the royal family
so they're now going to pursue this from
california
and leave the british royal family
to proceed on its own way what that
means for canada
i don't know but that's that's your
decision you've
you're now between these two branches of
the world
and then sorry a lot of people compare
this to the abdication
of 1936 when edward viii was sent
into exile um because he wanted to marry
an american divorcee
another american divorcee causing
trouble
um and um he went into exile he
published his memoirs and then he shut
up
what we have to remember is that this
couple are not going to shut
up they're going to keep talking and the
other thing to remember
about them is that although they have
their reservations about social media
they are plugged right into social media
they are like the trumps
of the british royal family they connect
with their public and their followers
directly through the the the messages
they send out and um just as president
trump
um got you know got elected in the first
place anyway
um through this method um so
harry and megan are going to go on um
commanding their own followership around
the world
and that's going to be a new dimension
for the royal family to cope with
now do you think prince harry's
experience of the spare air
will will better shape princess
charlotte and prince louie's future will
will
there be any lessons to be learned
well yes very good question there you're
saying
you're asking there are spares coming up
in the next generation
how are they going to um cope um
what is interesting is that prince
william has already
acknowledged that some of the problems
come from the way in which
he and harry were brought up right as i
say
william took one lesson from it that
duty was the way ahead for him
harry took another lesson that love was
the way ahead for him
and that's the clash um but um
uh william also feels that
the whole concept of him becoming king
was just sort of
thrown his way casually i mean there's a
wonderful story about how
harry when he was four years old was
misbehaving in the back of a car
he's then he told him off he says i
don't have to behave
i'm not going to be king now at the age
of four this little boy's behavior
patterns
are shaped by this whole royal system
he's not going to be king
william of course is going to be king
and we know that from about the age of
six or seven
william started to take this very
seriously william has now said that he
feels that in a way
he was robbed of his youth by this
um and so he
we are told has not yet informed little
prince george
uh in the next generation that he's
destined to be king when he took part in
a picture
um last december released in january
which we call over here the four
monarchs because it's elizabeth
ii charles william and little george
he was just told he was in the picture
to give support to gangan
to to to to the queen and show how much
everybody loved her
he didn't know he was standing there as
the future
king george vii um and so you know this
is
an example of how william um has
certainly applied a lot of thought to
the problem
and he's trying to come up with a new
solution
okay i really yeah that's that's really
fascinating too because obviously
he knows his experience and what's
happened with him and his brother and
and you're right he has his children to
look out for
um can we talk about the crown you work
as a historian on the show a lot of
people are very
very excited for season four um what can
you tell us about how the show is going
to portray the relationship between
queen elizabeth and and margaret
thatcher in that historic meeting
well you've put your finger on
what is going to be the essence of the
show
it goes between the years 1978
to 89 or so and of course
these are years of great royal turmoil
these will be the years when we meet
diana we've already
met camilla in previous um episodes and
seen charles's growing commitment to her
now we're going to see diana we're
actually going to see the birth
of my heroes william and harry and we're
going to see the beginning of the
turmoil
that shapes them and misshapes them but
um yes peter morgan who's the real
creator of the show i'm just one of a
bunch of historians who tries to give
him help
has fixed on the fact that these are the
years when
uh martin elizabeth ii has her first
female prime minister
margaret thatcher a woman whom to start
with she dislikes whose ideas she
dislikes
she's played by this brilliant actress
julian addison
and um that will be the big theme of the
show the way in which the queen's
attitude towards her changes um
and the show will in fact end with the
with the ending of power of
of margaret thatcher i think that's what
people find
fascinating in the crown they we we see
in the audience
we see the queen sitting there she
presses the button
um and in comes you know the most
powerful person in the country in theory
but they have to curtsy or bow to
the monarch um and maybe that's why you
still keep our
strange old british system because it's
good to have
something above the politicians to which
they have to pay
respect and whatever the faults of the
british crown or the canadian crown
um it's what many people want it's what
many people
love people give their emotions to this
family
sometimes i wonder why but we do and
um they're up there above all those
politicians
and it's very good that politicians have
to bow their heads to
somebody and that's what the crown
reminds us of
um now there is a scene in the trailer
with uh princess diana telling queen
elizabeth all i want is to be loved
um a lot of people are talking about
that moment did that moment actually
happen
in real life um it's like a number of
episodes in the crown
it it it draws on the message
of of of the character um
i mean for example um when we meet diana
i think in this season
we're not going to meet actually in a
plowed field which is where
charles first met her but i think it's
in some way at a school play
um where she's acting and um the point
of this
is that all royals are actors and diana
proved to be one of the most successful
actresses of
all and that's not to denigrate her and
say she was superficial
but the ability to project
your personality and your values is a
very important aspect of
of being royal and that'll be one of the
themes of the new season
so that that was going to be my next
question so essentially the idea of
our uh perception of diana the the
public's perception
um it will be looked at but but also
really explored kind of the reality
of who princess diana was and her
relationship with prince charles
well diana was such a wonderfully
complex character
and many of us over here see parallels
between her character
and meghan markle has harry married his
mother
we allowed to ask that i mean here is a
woman who was both
victim um and and admired and beloved
and sympathized with as a victim
but also very feisty who fought back
against the royal family
i mean we're just coming up to the the
uh what's the 25th anniversary of her
famous
panorama broadcast in britain when she
talked about three in a marriage
um when she talked about her doubts as
to whether
charles could ever become king
nothing like that had ever been seen
before in royal life
it took the royals into a new dimension
and so those are all some of the things
that we'll see the beginnings of
with this um you know absolutely
fantastic and intriguing diana character
yeah um you know in terms of this season
compared to the previous seasons every
season has been so fantastic
um do you have a favorite season of the
crown um
not favorite season i have favorite
episodes i loved the episode
when queen elizabeth ii got so close to
dr billy graham
the american evangelist who knew um
well i did but um who knew outside that
elizabeth ii is an evangelical christian
who loves this american gospel um
um sumper and another episode i loved
was the moon landings i mean that i
think is one of the reasons people
identify with the crown
it links in with events of the time
and so we share prince philip's absolute
fascination
uh with the moon landings and the
astronauts
and as a lover of science he thinks
these men must have the ultimate
wisdom of the universe and then he meets
them
and god what ordinary they're like post
office clerks clerks
i mean you know and that's when he turns
himself
to deeper spiritual values so um
who knows if that really happened um
actually where i
we know that it didn't actually happen
as depicted there
but it contains a truth that i think
everybody
can understand and and relate to and and
that's why we
we love the crown